if everything in vintage watches you
could learn in four years you would
spend at least a full semester
just on the first 15 years of
speedmaster it is so
dense i mean you could get a doctorate
and it's ridiculous hi this is james
lambda from analog shift and on this
special edition of work from home
fine points we're gonna look at vintage
watches and who's wearing them
[Music]
john mayer's passion for rolex is
legendary
here he's wearing a rolex explorer ii
the explorer line has become
an absolute staple of the rolex
collection today
that has its dna in extreme
alpine sports the original explorer line
was
basically designed after the attempts of
everest by
hillary and tenzig norgay this
particular one has what we call a polar
white dial and likely dates to the early
to mid 1990s
this is a transitional model for rolex
that explored the use of different
materials as rolex moved from what we
consider
traditional manufacturing techniques
into the modern era
it is what many of us would refer to as
neo-vintage
neo-vintage is a new term for collectors
it
identifies an era of manufacture
that sort of blends traditional
manufacturing techniques and materials
with the future for the most part
rolex's from the 80s and 90s would fall
into this category
they use materials like sapphire
crystals instead of acrylic
they use tritium luminescent material uh
instead of
more modern luminova this is a
transition from the past
to the present what's interesting for
collectors today is that there's a lot
of really great bargains
in this era they're not properly vintage
but they're not the new stuff either
one of the reasons people are so
interested in neovintage is that they
still
have the ability to garner patina
newer watches have such high quality
materials that they won't break
down over time at least not in our
lifetimes so all they do is end up
looking
old and used whereas vintage watches
have this
tendency to develop really interesting
unique characteristics over time
that is why many collectors prefer
vintage they really truly
become unique it's very clear that john
mayer's love of rolex goes back
even further here we're looking at him
wearing the original
rolex explorer ii this is a rolex
reference
the explorer ii was actually originally
designed for spelunking
a sport in which you go underground for
perhaps
days at a time as a result they needed
the wearers of these watches the ability
to tell
what time it was without any reference
from the sun
so it has a 24 hour movement just like a
gmt
unlike a gmt master it does not have a
rotating bezel it has a fixed
steel bezel with 24 hours on it so
you'll always know
whether it's am or pm while you're
looking at the watch
these early explorer twos are often
referred to as
orange hand explorers this was a design
that
left the rolex catalog until the 2000s
when it was reintroduced and
today you can go into a rolex dealer and
find the new version
of this watch here john is wearing one
of the
kings of the rolex collection the rolex
daytona
what's notable about this particular
example is that it is an
oyster cosmograph daytona which is a
very long
name for what everyone just calls a
daytona in short it's only an
oyster if it has waterproof
case and in order to make a chronograph
waterproof you need to have
screw down pushers so if you look
carefully at those stop watch buttons
where you start
stop and reset the movement you'll
notice that they have a little flange
that can be screwed down
to be waterproof underwater it also has
an acrylic crystal
and it has that classic panda dial with
the silver
dial with black subsidiary registers if
you have the reverse with a black back
and lighter colored subsidiary registers
they are affectionately referred to as
reverse pandas maroon 5's adam levine
clearly has a great taste in vintage
rolexes this
is the paul newman daytona paul newman's
daytona was recently sold for
eye-watering 17.8 million dollars
at auction here in new york just a
couple years ago but what's interesting
about the paul newman daytona model
was that the stylized decoration on the
dial was originally
completely uninteresting to consumers
these watches
languished on store shelves for up to a
decade
and eventually sold for their original
retail of just a few hundred dollars
as the legend goes paul newman was
gifted one of these
and he just wore it with somewhat
abandoned and actually gave his watch to
his daughter's ex-boyfriend as a gift
when he found out he didn't have a watch
to tell the time it wasn't until many
years later that an italian magazine
reportedly published a photograph of
paul newman wearing the watch
and it was picked up by an early breed
of european vintage watch enthusiasts
it was nicknamed the paul newman daytona
anything that's got a nickname is pretty
much a sure thing in the collector
community
this particular reference has pumper
pushers that don't screw down so it's
not considered a waterproof oyster model
but it does have that wonderful panda
dial configuration
here adam is wearing the original rolex
submariner
this is a reference 6538 also known as
a big crown submariner this is the same
model that was popularized by sean
connery
in the james bond film thunderball what
makes these watches so desirable and
different than their current
submariner counterparts is that they
don't have crown guards they don't have
those little
protective elements on the side of the
case to keep you from knocking into the
crowd
furthermore the crowns were you guessed
it big
they were oversized they were designed
to be easily grippable by gloved
wet suited hands for use underwater
these are very much the prototypical
submariners and they are one of the most
desirable
sought after and valuable vintage
watches on the planet
ellen degeneres ellen's real passion in
rolex is clearly the daytona she's got a
great collection of both vintage and
modern daytonas but here we're looking
at the ultimate grail
rolex daytona this is a paul newman
reference 6241
produced in solid gold this one also
carries the nickname
john player special as it references and
evokes
the color scheme of the racing livery of
the classic cigarette brand so the 6241
that she's got here features those
pumper pushers it features the black
acrylic bezel an oyster bracelet and
carries a price tag
pretty close to a million dollars today
daniel day kim here daniel is wearing my
favorite vintage rolex this is the
reference
1675 gmt master the gmt master was
originally
asked for by pan-american airline
executives
they asked rolex to create a watch that
could read two different time zones
for departure and destination as
intercontinental air travel
was beginning and they needed a watch
that could tell their pilot's time at
destination
and departure simultaneously the 1675
has developed a
absolutely cult-like following and is
popular in matte
and gilt dial variants steel gold
two-tone variants
and a variety of different bezel and
bracelet configurations
daniel's watch is fitted with what we
call a blueberry bezel because it is
all blue these are fairly controversial
bezels
in fact some collectors believe that
they are completely fake
rolex has never confirmed or denied for
the most part whether or not these
things were actually made
whether or not they were actually sold
at retail whether it could have been
some special order or some test bed that
never got produced
but there are a number of these things
out on the market they're very
collectible
they're very valuable and they're very
cool so whether or not they're
totally legit or just partially legit or
maybe not legit at all
it's a great look and daniel day kim
don't listen to anyone whether or not
it's real
fake or somewhere in between it's a
great looking watch
i love it here is the always stylish
bradley cooper
rocking a rolex gmt master two-tone
affectionately known as a root beer one
of the things that i love
so much about rolex gmts is that they
can be done
in any different number of
configurations and materials
without losing their level of cool
you can have a steel one you can have a
gold one you can have a golden steel one
you can have a black one a red one a
pepsi one a blueberry one a black dial
you can put it on an oyster bracelet a
jubilee bracelet you can put it on
leather
they're all cool bradley's here has that
brown dial and a bi-color
brown gold bezel which is the really
quintessential
root beer look that was popularized by
clint eastwood
in the 1970s
we've talked before about ryan gosling
and his rolex air king his
beautiful simple really base model rolex
that's been with him for a very long
time ryan's love of the simpler rolex
models
has even followed him on set here we see
a picture of him
working on crazy stupid love wearing a
rolex oyster
bubble back produced in yellow gold
what's really interesting about this
watch is it has a
california dial a california dial is
a name that no one really knows where it
came from
but it refers to a dial that has half
roman
and half arabic numerals scattered
around the dial
it's just something that was believed to
be popular in the 1930s it was used by
rolex it was used by panerai
and today it's more of a curiosity than
anything else but they are really cool
and they're a throwback
to a great era in rolex design
this particular model is referred to as
a bubble back because the back of the
case of the watch
was bubbled out this was an early form
of automatic watch that used a very
large rotor
that took up frankly quite a bit of room
so looking back
particularly from a perspective where
things have gotten smaller and thinner
and a little bit more precise this is a
sort of bulbous design
but they are desirable and actually
incredibly comfortable
sylvester stallone sly has a great
appreciation for watches
he's been tied with panerai and richard
mill and a number of other projects in
the last few years
showing that his love of large sporty
watches
is really all-consuming however it
wasn't always so
one of sly's favorite possessions is his
early rolex 1680-8
the earlier version of this watch an
18-carat gold submariner
that he bought after his success in
rocky the 1680 was the first rolex
submariner to feature a date
function previous iterations of the
submariner
simply told the time in hours minutes
and seconds
there's an old adage that if you need to
know what day it is while you're diving
underwater
you're properly but it's useful in
virtually every other
use in human life his watch actually has
a tiffany signature on the dial
indicating that it was purchased from a
tiffany store
it was an authorized partnership in the
1970s
and i think it makes that watch which is
already cool as hell
even cooler we've talked a lot about how
subtle differences can mean
huge value discrepancies with vintage
watches
unlike modern watches vintage watches
were
produced with materials that create
patina and no two watches will age the
same
another differentiating factor can be a
double signature on a dial
so you have the brand manufacturing
signature rolex omega
tiso longine audemars piguet you fill in
the blank but many of these brands
sold through partner stores that could
be tiffany or cartier
meister googlen any number those
secondary signatures printed on the dial
if they're genuine
can mean huge value increases to
collectors
however buyer beware it's relatively
easy to add a secondary signature to a
dial
at a much later date increasing the
value and pulling the wool over your
eyes
so if you are interested in buying one
of these slightly more special examples
i would highly encourage that you buy
from someone you know and can trust
mcdreamy patrick dempsey seen here
wearing a vintage hoyer monaco
hoyer as it was so known before was
acquired by
tag or technique avant-garde produced
some of the most
exceptional and beautiful racing style
chronographs
of the mid-century the golden era of
sports car racing
the monaco with its square shape was
introduced in 1969
and coincided with the launch of hoyer's
first automatic chronograph movement
the caliber 11. this particular example
is fitted with a gray dial with black
subsidiary registers
it's a deep cut and i love this watch
because
they're more commonly seen with the blue
dial with the white subsidiary registers
of course popularized by the king of
cool himself
steve mcqueen in this shot from the wolf
of wall street leonardo dicaprio is
wearing a tag heuer series 1000 diving
watch
this is kind of an interesting watch
it's very evocative of the era from a
design standpoint it is
reminiscent of a rolex submariner and it
also features a bracelet design that is
very similar to the rolex
jubilee style bracelet that you might
find on a datejust or a gmt master
but make no mistake this is not a super
high quality watch
it has that quartz movement inside with
the oscillating crystal instead of the
gears and springs of a proper mechanical
watch
and it's gold-plated it's not solid gold
it's probably why he takes it off and
throws it away part way through the
movie
daniel craig james bond himself
interestingly
despite the fact that he wears omega on
screen
he's also wearing omega off screen this
is a vintage
seamaster it's produced in steel has
subsidiary seconds which is a small
register just below the main hands that
run the seconds continually it's
beautiful this is classic
this is looks to be late 50s perhaps
early 60s
it is his personal watch and there he is
wearing it on
red carpet events proving that omega has
not lost
its sense of style ever
just like james bond prince william
here prince william is wearing an omega
seamaster 300 professional
this is a model that was popularized by
pierce brosnan's portrayal of james bond
in goldeneye
in 1996. it sort of signaled a
change in omega's design language and
one that they're still using today
i assume that prince williams does not
do any of the pretty cool things that
pierce brosnan's dead it's got no lasers
or bomb
detonators i imagine but it's still a
great look and it's a great classic
design
[Music]
matt scannell singer songwriter and
frontman of the great band vertical
horizon
matt has a wonderful collection of
vintage watches his love
is definitely focused on the omega
speedmaster the omega speedmaster was
chosen by nasa to accompany man on our
greatest accomplishment
landing on the moon this particular
watch which dates to the 1970s has a
tremendously beautiful
patina the tritium indices and hands
have faded to this creamy color and most
interestingly it has a double signature
on the dial
from the retailer meister the study of
omega speedmasters is a dense one
it is one of the most important and
popular vintage watches
of all time it is iconic in that it has
barely changed since its introduction in
1957. in fact yes
you can go out to an omega authorized
dealer right now and buy a watch that
looks
a whole lot like the ones that they were
producing in the 50s and 60s
the history is really really vibrant
it's interesting because the speedmaster
wasn't actually originally designed
to go to space it was actually designed
for
racing applications hence the name
speedmaster the
development of this watch has been
lockstep with advancements in
timekeeping and they're actually going
back to some of their routes
introducing new versions of some of
their earlier movements which
in an interesting twist of fate are
preferred by
many collectors
[Music]
in an earlier video we looked at kanye
west's cartier crash
here we're looking at angelina jolie
wearing an absolutely beautiful
vintage tank louis cartier this is the
watch that allegedly
proved the inspiration for the crash
when it came back
deformed from the heat of a car accident
the cartier tank louie drew its original
design inspiration from
world war one french battle tanks and as
you can see in the profile it features
two elongated edges
with a very simple and luxurious dial
printed roman indices
and blued steel hands these would have
featured an early
manual winding movement and were just as
beautiful then as they
are now and vice versa absolutely
timeless design
carl lagerfeld here we see the late
fashion tycoon
wearing an audemars piguet royal oak
this model is referred to as the jumbo
it was introduced in 1972 and was
designed by gerald genta for audemars
piguet
this watch was a absolute hail mary
during absolute
worst time in the swiss watchmaking
industry a time we refer to
as the quartz crisis this watch cost
way more than a gold rolex despite the
fact that it was produced in steel
it was a runaway success and is credited
with saving
the luxury sport watch category of the
industry
in fact it may have even created that
entire category all
its own carl lagerfeld is wearing this
watch
and he's got a couple interesting things
going on here one is that it's black
it might have been the first example of
a customized black watch
uh in history and secondly he's wearing
it over the cuff there's not too many
guys i know who could pull that off but
when you're karl lagerfeld
you want to paint your watch black and
wear it over your cuff
who's going to stop you collecting
vintage watches is one of the most
rewarding
components of wristwatch collecting
unlike modern watches these things each
have their own story and design
they have their own heritage they have
their own patina they're all unique
they're all
beautiful snowflakes but it's also a bit
of a minefield
you want to make sure that you follow a
few simple steps to make sure that
you're not getting taken
first and foremost buy the seller make
sure you're buying a watch from somebody
you know and can trust
secondly condition condition and
condition don't let anyone tell you that
you should be only looking at mint
condition watches in fact
patina and wear are part of the story
and part of the charm of these great old
things
but you do want to make sure that you're
buying what you want and you're not
being talked into
or settling for something less than you
want lastly
probably pay a little bit more than you
think you should because if it's a great
watch
and it's market value there's probably
something wrong with it
somebody would own it already so maybe
pay tomorrow's price or next month's
price
but if you follow those earlier steps
buying the seller and buying a great
watch
from the start you'll never have
anything to regret